les matches truqués ça ne se limite pas
du tout au tennis yona il y en a depuis
longtemps dans d'autres sports également
oui en fait en 1919 niveau des moines y
étions mieux un grand scandale dans le
monde du baseball c'était à l'époque les
white sox de chicago qui jouait contre
les l'ouest de cincinnati à l'époque
bien fait huit joueurs qui avaient
accepté 10 mille dollars chacun parce
qu'ils étaient sous payés résultat ils
ont été bannis à vie un sport aussi qui
connaît très souvent des scandale de
match truqué c'est bien sûr et
malheureusement le soccer est une norme
aimant de scandale beaucoup de matches
truqués encore l'année dernière un des
plus connus c'est en 1980 il y avait la
sphère tonero en italie avait trente
joueurs qui avaient été impliqués dont
des joueurs de l'ac milan évidemment on
se rappellera aussi en 93 l'olympique de
marseille qui était dirigé à l'époque
par le l'homme d'affaires bernard tapie
qui avait proposé en fait à trois
joueurs de valenciennes contre lequel
ils allaient jouer de lever un peu la
[ __ ] évidemment un autre scandale ils
ont été relégués en deuxième division
après cela et puis il ya d'autres sports
un peu plus ésotériques pour nous mais
heymans aimant populaire dans certains
pays par exemple creek est plus
populaire que le hockey à la télévision
ailleurs dans le monde des scandales en
inde en afrique du sud et au pakistan
et puis le snooker ou si vous savez ces
grandes tables de billard il y avait 1
le champion stifani lui qui avait
influencé jusqu'à huit rencontres et
bien résultat il était banni jusqu'en
mais il faut dire que s'il ya beaucoup
de parieurs il ya beaucoup d'argent et
d'où cette corruption on parle du tennis
mais ça existe aussi ailleurs oui en
fait il ya un chiffre qui donne vraiment
le vertige en fait on estime le marché
des paris sportifs dans le monde à 600
milliards de dollars ça c'est sans
compter tous les autres milliards qui se
font de façon clandestine et et sous
marins au canada c'est à peu près 15
milliards et demi alors il faut savoir
que là dedans il ya du blanchiment
d'argent de l'argent sale qui est
investi par les mafias notamment en
chine principalement en asie 140
milliards de dollars donc d'argent sale
qui sont investis dans le domaine des
paris sportifs s'étaient n'a alors que
font les pays les organismes sportifs
pour tenter de contrer ces matches
truqués
alors il ya beaucoup d'organisations qui
se sont créées par exemple en europe on
a créé l'association pour la
surveillance pour la sécurité
l'intégrité du sport bon et ça y est
également
le monde des loteries qui s'est mis à la
page sans oublier la fifa aussi le
problème c'est que ce soit les
organismes qui bien souvent sont
limitées en terme de champ d'action
parce que à cause d'internet et à cause
de tout cet argent sale qui est injecté
dans les paris sportifs que ce soit par
les les mafias des balkans la mafia
chinoise ou russe c'est bien ça devient
difficile de retracer donc des
associations qui font des efforts il est
difficile en réalité de voir leur
efficacité réelle intéressant merci il
faudrait qu'ils ont appris